for people who don't know
how long have you been rapping so i've
been rapping probably for like
i want to say 10 years
but like really like really really
rapping for probably like
seven years like yeah about that and so
for uh like i'm
you originally did did farewell kind of
discover you like kind of give us a
background on you and pharrell like
like back back when you kind of cause i
think that's how maybe some people might
have first heard of you so
actually family discovered me shout out
to family yeah
virginia he's the original because like
you know nobody believed
in me until he did and then you know
it was just just him believing in me for
a long time and then you know then
pharrell
and and it was just it's really hard
when you have to put
all that pressure on on just only two
people like you know what i'm saying
to try to get the world to see what you
see that early on
is like it's very hard to do and you
know i respect and love them forever for
doing that for me because
when you stamp something that early it's
like that's genuine